.
HAPPY HALLOWEEN APPARENTLY I
WOULDN'T KNOW.
I DON'T CARE.
BY NOW YOU HEARD ABOUT THE
ATTACK ON PAUL PELOSI A SUSPECT
IN CUSTODY APPARENTLY A HOMELES
ILLEGAL ALIEN.
HE LIVED IN OLD YELLOW SCHOOL
BUS.
NO TRUTH TO THE RUMOR IT WAS
DANNY PARTRIDGE.
DON'T NOKIA WAS BUS.
WE KNOW HOW WONDERFUL THOSE
THINGS ARE.
>> WHO DOESN'T LOVE A YELLOW
SCHOOL BUS?
RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU HAVE A
YELLOW SCHOOL BUS.
THERE IS SOMETHING ABOUT MOST O
US IN MANY OF US WENT TO SCHOOL
ON THE YELLOW SCHOOL BUS.
AND IT'S PART OF OUR EXPERIENCE
GROWING UP.
>> SO TRUE.
SHE LOVES SCHOOL BUSES ALMOST A
MUCH AS SHE LOVES IT BEEN
DIAGRAMS BE BACK MEANWHILE IN
THE MEDIA YET DAMS AND TALKING
HEADS IT DESPERATELY TRYING TO
MAKE IT ABOUT RIGHT WING HATE.
IT PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT WERE
ALWAYS SAYING YOU'VE GOT A GO
ATTACK ME NANCY'S HUSBAND WITH
CAMERA DON'T WEAR PANTS.
>> HE WAS YELLING OUT THINGS WE
HEARD DURING JANUARY 6 WHICH IS
WHERE IS NANCY.
>> THAT'S WHAT THE INTRUDERS
GOING TO THE HALLWAYS ON JANUAR.
THIS IS PART OF THE JANUARY 6
INSURRECTION.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS.
AT ATTACKS ON HER AND THAT THIS
GROUP OF MAKKAH EXTREMISTS
HAVEN'T BEEN NOT ENDING WHEN
DONALD TRUMP LEFT OFFICE.
>> THIS IS PART OF JANUARY 1.
IT'S MAGUS EXTREME IS BEHIND
THIS WHO LIVE IN SCHOOL BUSES
WHO THINK THEIR JESUS CHRIST.
MARGA MAGA THE MEDIA CAN'T BE
DUMB ENOUGH TO PLAY ON CAMPAIGN
ADS.
>> LOOKING AT YOUR CANDIDATES,
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES HAVE SPEN
MORE THAN A HUNDRED 60 MILLION
ON ADS NANCY PELOSI BY NAME IN
THE CYCLE.
IF IT'S ABOUT THE ISSUES, MAKE
IT ABOUT THE ISSUES OF.
WHY NOT DEPERSONALIZE IT?
THIS MOMENT WE ARE EIGHT DAYS
OUT, DON'T YOU THINK IT NEEDS T
CHANGE?
WHY NOT PULL THESE ADS OR DELET
YOUR TWEET?
>> LATE TO DELETE YOUR BRAIN.
YOU SHOULD STOP THE AIR THAT
ADDS EIGHT DAYS OUT.
WHAT A COINCIDENCE THAT YOU
WOULD USE AT THIS FOR THAT
SUGGESTION.
DO THESE PEOPLE THINK BEFORE
THEY SAY ANYTHING?
MARGARET, MOMO CBS DEPERSONALIZ
THEIR CONTACT?
MAYBE START WITH YOUNG SHELDON.
WHATEVER THAT IS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS OR HO
ABOUT COLD AIR WHO HAS DONE
NOTHING BUT STAY UNCIVIL STUFF
ABOUT REPUBLICANS.
HOW MANY ATTACKS THAT HE CAUSED?
I WOULD NEVER SUGGEST THAT
BECAUSE OF THAT DEPLETE.
>> EDDIE AT A BLEAT.
>> I HAVEN'T HAD A LOT OF SLEEP.
I'M NOT AWAKE.
PEOPLE FREAKING OUT NEVER DID S
AFTER SCHOOL HE'S GOT SHARP
FRIEND, AND A A TRUMP SUPPORTER
WAS RUN DOWN AND MURDERED.
REMEMBER HOW MANY JOKES WERE
MADE ABOUT RAND PAUL GETTING HI
RIBS LOOKING BLEEP.
>> IT'S THEIR REPUBLIC IS THAT
THEY CALL NAZIS WHO ARE CAUSING
A LACK OF STABILITY, I GET
ANYTHING FOR ELECTION.
IN THE DEPTHS OF LOSING WHICH
MEANS SOMEONE HAVE TO GET REAL
JOBS AND DEMOCRATS HATE JOBS.
REMEMBER, NEVER LET A CRISIS GO
TO WASTE EVEN IF IT IS SOMEONE'
DENTED SCHOOL.
THAT'S WHY EVEN WITH COVID, THE
DEMS ARE FORGETTING GETTING
STUDENTS.
NOTHING IS EVER CONNECTED.
IT'S EXPLOITED.
EVEN WITH THAT IN ELECTION THEY
PROBABLY DO THE SAME [ BLEEP! ]
THING.
LIKE LOUIS CHENEY USED TO DO.
DID HE COMPARE HER TO HIM?
>> I HOPE SO.
I HOPE YOU THINK THAT, YOU IDIOT
.
REPUBLICANS FOCUS ON CRIME.
HOME INVASIONS ARE UP AS OUR
MURDERS, RAPES AND ROBBERIES.
IN PLACES WHERE POLITICIANS
ADVOCATED TO DEFUNDING THE COPS.
YOU CAN CAUSE A POLITICAL TAKE
EXCEPT THIS ONE IS ROOTED IN
REALITY.
A SUPPOSE REPUBLICANS COULD'VE
MADE UP STUFF AS WELL LIKE
THEIRS IS A WINNING GAVEL FOUND
AT THE SCENE.
>> THEY DIDN'T.
AND SO THE MEDIA SCREECHES LIKE
CAMO KEMAL HARRIS HAVING HER
FEET TICKLED.
HOW DARE YOU BRING UP VIOLENT
CRIME EVEN AFTER A VIOLENT CRIM
IS COMMITTED.
WE WILL SMACK ALL OF YOU WITH
HAMMERS.
YOU'RE ONLY SUPPOSED TO TALK
VIOLENT CRIME FOR FAKE VIOLENT
CRIMES THERE ARE LESSONS HERE
BUT POLITICIANS AND THE MEDIA O
INTERESTED IT'S ABOUT ONLY
POLITICAL OUTCOMES.
>> NOW IT'S THE POLUZZI ATTACK
WAS MAGA.
JANUARY 6.
A HATE SPEECH IT WAS A CONSTANT
THREAT.
IT'S CODE FOR CRITICIZING
DEMOCRATS.
AS LONG AS THEY WENT IN NOVEMBER
, NOTHING EVER NEEDS
FIXING.
THAT'S WHY THE CRIMINALLY
DERANGED ARE STILL ON THE STREET
.
THAT'S WHY THIS HAPPENED.
THERE'S NOWHERE FOR THE MENTALL
ILL TO GO.
BOTTOM LINE IF PELOSI HAD BEEN
ANOTHER VICTIM, WHO KNOWS IF
THEY GIVE A AT ALL ABOUT THIS.
IF IT WAS JUST AN ASIAN LADY,
WE'D BE TOLD TO BE PEOPLE WITH
HAMMER IS A MISDEMEANOR.
THE MEDIA HELPS BY AMPLIFYING
THE FAKE ORIGIN TO AVOID THE
REAL ONE.
THE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS.
IT GOES IGNORED LIKE JOY BEHAR
IT'S SEX STRIKE.
CALIFORNIA STATE LOGO SHOULD BE
A BEAR IN A STRAITJACKET.
WITHOUT ALL THE HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS, THE NEW STATE MOTT
SHOULD BE THE GOLDEN SHOWER
STATE.
THEIR STATE BAR, A $1.7 MILLION
TOILET.
I KNOW IT'S NOT A BIRD.
THEY DON'T HAVE A STATE
APPLIANCE.
SO THE SUSPECT WAS A HOMELESS
PSYCHOTIC LIKE TENS OF THOUSAND
ON THE STREETS.
THERE A DANGER TO YOU BUT NOW
ALSO TO POLITICIANS AND SPOUSES
THE THINGS THAT HAPPENED
EVERYONE ELSE ELSE FINALLY
HAPPENED TO SOMEONE WHO MATTERS.
THE HUSBAND OF THE SPEAKER HE I
NOT A COP A RETIREE OR A STUDENT
, HE IS RICH AND POWERFUL
AND IF THEY THROW THE BOOK AT
THE SUSPECT, THEY SURE AS HELL
BETTER DO THE SAME FOR EVERY
OTHER FELON BECAUSE AT THIS IS
CRIME IF IT'S TIME FOR
PUNISHMENT AND NOT JUSTIFY THE
IMPORTANT VICTIMS, BUT FOR
EVERYONE.
WITH THE DEMS, WHILE THEY CARE?
THEY SERVE A PURPOSE HE GAVE
BIDEN SOMETHING TO TALK ABOUT
BETWEEN LYING ABOUT GAS PRICES
AND THAT LINE HE WAS RAISED BY
PUERTO RICANS A MENTALLY
DERANGED DRUG ABUSED AT NAKED
NOT THAT BAG FINDS ITS WAY TO
THE POLUZZI HOME IN THE MEDIA
STOPS AND ONE TALKING POINT.
THEIR IDEA OF INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTING.
LIKE SO MANY CRIME VICTIMS, PAU
AND NANCY MAY NEVER BE THE SAME.
MAYBE IT'S TIME TO MOVE TO
FLORIDA.
THAT'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
WHEN SHE CALLS CALLS A SHOTGUN,
THAT MEANS SHE'S GOING TO KILL
AN ANTELOPE.
HUNTING LEGENDS OF AMERICA FOX
NATION.
>> SHE IS LESS WELCOME AND HOLL
WENT THAN ADDICTION COUNSELOR
FORMER TRUMP DEPUTY ASSISTANT
SECRETARY AMANDA.
THEY SAY YOU SHOULD DRESS FOR
THE JOB YOU WANT SO YOU MUST
WANT TO BE UNEMPLOYED.
AND IT FINALLY, HALLOWEEN
SKELETONS CALLED BONY.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KEPT HIM
AMANDA, NICE COSTUME.
>> THINK THANK YOU.
>> WHO ARE YOU GOING AS.
>> I WAS TOLD IT WAS HALLOWEEN
AND WE WERE HAVING A HALLOWEEN
PARTY.
>> THE ONLY TWO THAT SHOWED UP
YOU AS A SKELETON OF MICHAEL
LOFTUS AS K.D. LANG.
>> CAN'T SHOHEI PICTURE OF HIM
THERE WOULD BE TOO MUCH WORK FO
THE DIRECTOR.
>> GOOD JOB.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS BEING--
YOU BELIEVE LEE DOES
WOULD TO JANUARY 6?
>> ALWAYS.
>> YOU KEENLY GET ANYTHING TO
JANUARY 6.
YOU MY CAT DIDN'T FINISH IT'S A
FOOD IT TO JANUARY 6.
I PERSONALLY FEEL VICTIMIZED.
I WILL CALL THE FBI.
EXCEPT THE PROBABLY ALREADY AT
MY HOUSE.
THERE WAS VIRTUALLY NOTHING NO
MATTER HOW MANY YEARS GO BY THA
YOU CAN'T LINK TO JANUARY 6.
IT IS A FIRST OF ALL WORSE THAN
PEARL HARBOR.
DEFINITELY WORSE THAN 9/11.
EXCEPT NOBODY DIED.
EXCEPT IT ONE OF OURS.
IT'S REALLY JUST ONLY RIVALS AN
MYSTERY THAT AT THE LAS VEGAS
SHEETING.
THE PIPE VAUGHN OR JUST WALKING
AROUND BOMBING PLACES.
>> WE DON'T KNOW IT COULD BE
NANCY THAT COULD BE WHO WENT TO
NANCY PELOSI'S HOUSE THE FBI
SHOULD LOOK INTO THIS.
>> IS TRUE LOFTUS OR KATIE.
>> BEFORE WE GO I WANT YOU TO
JOIN ME FOR HALLOWEEN.
>> WELCOME TO THE CLUB.
>> ACTUALLY, I'VE FELT A LOT
BETTER YOU HAVE MORE WORK THAN
ONE OF THEM BEING.
>> HOW MANY PACKS OF CIGARETTES
DO YOU SMOKE?
>> SEVEN A DAY.
>> IT SMELLS LIKE MARGE SIMPSON
'S SISTER I THINK I'M
GETTING CANCER.
I'M GOING TO PUT THIS OVER HERE
IT IS TRUE JANUARY 6 IS THE
KEVIN BACON OF CONSPIRACIES.
THEY CAN'T STOP THEY SHOULD'VE
LEFT IT AS A CRAZY PERSON
ATTACKED AN INNOCENT MAN IN
AMERICA WOULD'VE BEEN LIKE
THAT'S HORRIFYING BUT THEY HAVE
TO TRY TO NOT LET A CRISIS GO T
WASTE.
AS SOON AS THEY PUT IT ON THE
RADAR, YOU START LOOKING AT IT
AND THEN THE MORE YOU START
LOOKING, IT'S LIKE PEE-WEE
HERMAN GETTING THE CABLE THAT
SWEATER IT GETS WEIRDER AND
WEIRDER.
HE WAS A RADICAL NUDIST SO I
GUESS WHEN HE SHOWS UP AND
UNDERWEAR, THAT'S LIKE RESPECT.
THAT'S LIKE HE WENT TO LIKE IT
WAS A JOB INTERVIEW.
I'M OFF TO ATTACK PAUL PELOSI
IT'S CRAZY.
>> IT WHEN I SPEAK TO BE CLEARE
AT ALL THIS UP THAT'S WHY EMMA
START A GO FOR ME SO THE PELOSI
'S CAN GET A RING DOORBELL
.
BE BACK IT'S AMAZING WHAT NET B
NICE TO SEE SOME KIND OF
SECURITY CAMERA.
>> THIS SHOULD BE A LESSON TO
THEM THEY LIVE IN A BEAUTIFUL
AREA IN SAN FRANCISCO AND THEY
ASSUME TO YOUR POINT THAT THOSE
WINDOWS ARE EASILY BROKEN BUT
LIKE THERE WILL PROTECTED BUT
ALSO THE OTHER THING THEY CAN'T
DO IS TALK ABOUT CRIME.
THAT FEEDS INTO THE NARRATIVE
THAT'S WHY THEY WENT FOR THE
JANUARY 6 EXTREME MAGA BECAUSE
IF YOU'RE SAYING WHILE EVEN THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE IT'S A
HORRIBLE TIME FOR THEM TO BRING
UP DEFENDING THE POLICE.
>> FIRST ABOUT, I CAN'T BELIEVE
YOU BROUGHT OUT FREIGHT TO CLIN
ON A LATE NIGHT SHOW.
A LITTLE WEIRD BUT THE SUSPECT
OF THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THE
FELLOW WHO BROKE IN WITH A
HAMMER HE'S NOT ACTING LIKE A
NICE CANADIAN.
>> IT'S VERY ODD BEHAVIOR.
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT THEY CAN TALK
ABOUT THE ISSUE IT'S AMAZING TO
WATCH MARGARET BRENNAN AND
PRORATING A REPUBLICAN ABOUT
PULLING ADS DURING AN ELECTION
BY THE SAKE OF MORALITY.
THAT WOULD BE THE RIGHT THING T
DO BUT CONTINUE AND NOT
DEMOCRATS TOO RUN THEIR ADS
WHICH I'M SURE HAVE NO
INSINUATION OF ANYTHING ABOUT
GOING AFTER REPUBLICANS WHEN
MENTIONING KEVIN MCCARTHY.
>> IT IS A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY
BUT SHE ALSO MISSES THE POINT
SHE SAYS IS AN ABOUT THE ISSUES?
IT'S ABOUT CRIME AND THEY CAN'T
TALK ABOUT IT BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN INDICTED ON THEIR OWN
IDEOLOGY WHICH THEY REFUSED TO
CHANGE.
THEY BELIEVE IN ALLOWING
CRIMINALS TO RUN THE STREETS
UNLESS THEY'RE BREAKING INTO
SOMEONE'S HOUSE WHO DESERVES
PROTECTION.
WHAT YOU SAY ABOUT THINGS
GETTING WEIRDER I DON'T BUY
THERE WAS NOT SECURITY I THINK
WE WILL LEARN A LOT MORE ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED OUTSIDE THE HOUSE.
IT'S A LITTLE STRANGE IF JANUAR
WENT HAVE FULL SECURITY.
>> MAYBE SHE WAS NOT THERE THAT
COULD BE AT MAYBE HE DOESN'T
LIKE SECURITY I DON'T KNOW ADAM
WENT TO GET INTO THE PRIVATE
LIVES GOD KNOWS MINE IS SCREWED
UP.
>> CAT, WHAT ABOUT THIS WHOLE
THING ABOUT MENTAL ILLNESS?
THIS GUY IS COMPLETELY BONKERS.
HE'S GOT NO CONSISTENT POLITICA
IDEOLOGY.
HE'S ALMOST A LIBERTARIAN.
>> LIBERTARIAN IS IN A
CONSISTENT IDEOLOGY.
LESS GOVERNMENT IS WHAT I WANT.
I SPENT ENOUGH TIME ON ONE FOR
FEW YEARS WERE HONESTLY MORE
TIME THAN ANYWHERE ELSE.
WHAT IS IT LED TO?
THEIR ACTING AS THOUGH THIS GUY
IS LIKE HE WAS A NORMAL GUY IN
CHILD LIKE A MEDICAL SALES REP
OR SOMETHING.
HE HEARD TRUMP TALK AND THEN AL
OF A SUDDEN NOW HE'S DOING THAT
STUFF ALL KINDS OF CRAZY STUFF
LIKE JESUS IS THE ANTICHRIST HE
IS JESUS NONE OF THESE THINGS
ARE MOCK A TALKING POINTS THAT
THERE IS A CRAZY PERSON AND ALS
DON'T THINK I DON'T KNOW HOW
THEY'RE SPENDING THIS NARRATIVE
ANYONE IS LIKE PRO THIS
NECESSARILY BECAUSE THEY SAY
PEOPLE REFUSED TO CONDEMN NOT
CONDEMNING SOMETHING--NOT
POSTING A TWEET LIKE I'M SAD AN
SICKENED AND DISGUSTED THERE AL
THE SAME THING.
IT NOT DOING THAT DOES NOT MEAN
YOU CAN'T THINK THAT WAY IT
MEANS YOU DIDN'T TWEET IT.
>> YOU HAVE TO DO THAT SIGNAL
AND NO ONE WILL LIKE IT ANYWAY
WHILE ANOTHER THING BECAUSE
CONSERVATIVES HAVE BEEN
CONSISTENT AND OPPOSING VIOLENC
THAT IS A METHOD AND A
COOKIE-CUTTER VERSION TO CONDEM
VIOLENCE.
IT DOES NOT COUNT